[Music]
today you boys will be involved in such
activities as board games
ambush techniques then blowing stuff up
i don't think i can do this of course
you can
come when i was your age i had an
imaginary friend
got me in so much trouble
kids it's time to burn some books
keep growing up too fast 10 year olds
shouldn't be celebrating war and talking
politics
i wish more of our young boys had your
blind fanaticism
did you know jews can read each other's
minds but how would you know if you saw
one
they could look just like us hi
[Music]
what am i going to do no idea got it
i'm gonna go down the house and blame
winston churchill
or negotiate if i tell on you
you'll be in big trouble
they'll never win that is the strongest
thing in the world your mother took me
in
she's kind she treats me like a person
you two seem to be getting on well she
doesn't seem like a bad person
i'm the enemy you're not a nazi jojo
you're a ten-year-old kid
who likes dressing up in a funny uniform
and wants to be part of the club
oh god nothing makes sense anymore yeah
i know it's definitely not a good time
to be a nazi
[Music]
you